tu commercial est au début et non je
procède plutôt style styliste outre donc
rien à voir je pense que si on peut
concilier sont sa passion avec travail
c'est le but ultime de tout un chacun
est essentielle pour certains
alimentaire pour d'autres au moment où
le gouvernement réforme les règles du
jeu
quel rapport les français entretiennent
ils avec le travail peut-on être heureux
dans son boulot dans cette émission nous
donnerons la parole à olivier qui a
troqué son costume de cadre pour le bleu
de travail
je suis à ma place ça y est j'y suis
arnaud chef d'entreprise victime d'un
burn out et charlotte qui a la lourde
charge de rendre heureux les salariés on
lui apporte plus que du but faciliter la
vie on lui apporte du bien-être sur son
lieu de travail
ma voix compte
c'est sur public sénat